[Applause]
a shrine they're gone for the wind from
three
[Applause]
we chapter they want to vote on what
soon
[Applause]
oh that good you might want to challenge
that we they are good Nick nerd I think
they are I gotta see this again muffled
this is so close I don't know this is
the second challenge did he take it to
the rim to City it is so close it is
close
I mean this is so Anthony Davis control
party blah blah
and the glove of the three again
the captain garden
[Applause]
he was going mad at Adam so walk her
back 14 Yanis now play by heart gets a
pick cut the rowers Yanis ends up John
roll against LeBron
there's where we are afraid
and he would run back any possessions
and again with a chance to what it was a
three
[Applause]
Vogl can challenge because they want to
use their challenge I'll tell you what
it was a late call but it might have
been the right call
[Music]
this is unbelievable officials get the
assignment for all stuff yes pretty easy
to deal with what takes place hot
tonight
now here's the day I wish all three
quarters of like this fourth quarter
though Holly how they're playing Reggie
we got it we got it a little at a time
now this fourth quarter has been
unbelievable really has been how about
Kyle Lowry the defense that's two
charges two we try to take to an open
court and then that last play right
there that's a good call that's that
good call good call then look at
celebrity row everyone is out of their
seats to my right yeah
cardi B you guys to change spike
Walker watched by Leonard
and we get a whistle away from the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
Kyle Lowry that's it is on Lowry his
third yes and yes John Stockton screen
right there that's the correct call back
comes team LeBron against meeting of
three for the winners
[Applause]
that's okay you're still in the game if
you're seeing me on it but you
absolutely have to get a basket and it
stopped
you can't even foul because you can't
send him to the free-throw line either
you just need a bucket right here and
the ball is deflected out of bounds of
test
[Applause]
we can win it right here
LeBron James going against Jonathan
Kokubo for the win trick set by Paul
[Applause]
Paul played by Walker's fine for the
shots but this pose for the wind chase
town by lowering Walker looking for 30
[Applause]
[Music]
James and B took some download
last his funny way of traveled we got a
call
he's fortunately he kicked nuts he was
not called for the travel aplenty Swift
and or three seconds too
[Applause]
looks like he maintained his pivot foot
right there but lebra huh boss head
fighting the big fellow almost forms him
into a turnover and beat us for of 6 at
the line
do they have another stop in them them
and you can't foul and sitting to the
free-throw line first at 157
depends how many times we heard out from
coaches man
can you play defense without fire Xavier
bounds
[Applause]
looking to Davis the other way his poll
to LeBron
this volume that already
LeBron played by Yanis captain guarding
one another there's the pass to Davis we
got a once-over filed as cold so Davis
to the line he could work for so aligned
mid smash with Lowery it's over LeBron
is saying Anthony Davis at 85 percent
free-throw shooter making his first
appearance at the line challenged guess
they are challenging that call now this
will be they review that that one was a
review don't say that see every team's
the same didn't they challenge the other
one knows that was a review on the Gold
team there by the honest versus LeBron
[Music]
so once again here's the food question I
can't see his left arm pulling him down
it's hard to see from that angle
if Flowery grabbed his arm granted
that's a foul
I'm at mad at Lowry for trying no that's
a good call
[Music]
yes
force your rights 8g LeBron thought that
they had already is the challenge as we
thought and then it turns out we got
word it was just a review of a bottle to
let us well if the officials determined
that it is a foul and Anthony Davis goes
to the line it's only City as you say
the hometown back to Chicago right what
a great weekend and a chance to win the
game for Team LeBron
challenge unsuccessful so it was a foul
Paulo Alawi and Anthony Davis just beat
one free throw and it's all over Joel
and beats how to get it today this is my
friend Davis laughing about it
[Music]
the teens abroad looking to wrap it up
or trade me $300,000
- team of wrongs charity Chicago
scholars
[Applause]
[Music]
is not over yet wait a minute
you got to be kidding me a pressure of
free throw for Davis and now you got a
box out soon you've got a box out too
are you dreaming
[Applause]
wait